c'est giorgio pour france 3 centre val
de loire on se retrouve au printemps de
bourges
le meilleur blaze je dirais booba dans
une interview j'avais entendu un mec
dire on lui avait dit ouais pourquoi ce
buzz là il a dit puisque bullois s'était
déjà pris c'est la meilleure réponse
du coup meilleure place je dirais houba
en fait non pas du tout j'avais vu ça
une fois que j'ai annoncé que l'album
s'appellera bleu noir qui avaient déjà
un album qui s'appelle comme ça de
mylène farmer mais je me suis dit rien à
j'étais trop content j'ai que des
bons souvenirs là bas
ouais j'avais joué au w pour sur le ra
tour et j'avais fait la salle est ouest
en 2014 à l'époque d' à l'abri et je
crois que c'est même mon tout premier
festival
je te dirais le morceau avec valdes tu
sais ce qui se passe qu'on a enregistré
chez moi mon salon à l'époque
j'aimerais bien faire un morceau avec
rim k ça me fait kiffer j'ai hâte de
voir akira quoi elle ressemblera sur
scène et j'en sais rien aussi
si j'avais été un autre rappeur j'aurais
j'aurais bien les maîtres tupac c'est de
la merde je supporte pas d'entendre ça
c'est magnifique
tout l'inversé quoi venez nombreux et on
va le faire ensemble ça va être une
super soirée drap